[Musique]
c'est une bombe lancée par Benjamin
Castaldi vendredi dernier on va aller
jusqu'à 10 doses de rappel le
gouvernement qui prévoitrait jusqu'à 10
doses de rappel soit une dose de vaccin
tous les trois mois une nouvelle qui n'a
pas l'air de réjouir les Français et
surtout le rappeur Booba et moi j'ai une
autre info qui est extra confidentielle
mais je vous la révèle aujourd'hui en
exclusivité et cette info c'est qu'on
l'a dans le cul pourtant Benjamin
Castaldi affirme que les logiciels
médicaux seraient déjà programmés dans
ce sens j'ai une personne bien passée
qui a qui fait des vaccins qui à ce son
nouveau logiciel et en fait là on est à
rappel de 4 doses et on en fait on va
aller jusqu'à 10 on rappelle tous les
trois mois affirme que les scientifiques
travailleraient sur un vaccin annuel ils
essaient de trouver un seul vaccin pour
l'instant il y a pas qui serait une fois
par an pour le moment alors Benjamin
Castaldi annonce que le gouvernement
tablerait sur 10 doses par an et qu'il
est responsable alors c'est vrai que ce
sujet pour ce sujet vous l'attendez ce
soir qu'est-ce qui va se passer est-ce
qu'il va y avoir s'il te plaît d'abord
est-il irresponsable oui non Benjamin
Castaldi alors parlez pas de l'homme
l'ensemble de sa carrière jusqu'au
dollar
bien entendu je dois remercier le
professeur Enrique Casalino d'être avec
nous excellent directeur médical de
l'hôpital Bichat merci d'être là c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous avoir et ma
mériam Palomba ma journaliste
merci d'être là journaliste et bien sûr
amis de l'émission et amis de la France
Benjamin Castaldi vous avez jeté un pavé
dans la mare
vous avez dit vendredi qu'il allait
avoir 10 doses de vaccins c'est jusqu'à
dire c'est un truc de fou cette info
puisqu'elle a fait énormément réagir
vous étiez entêté et pas pour parler de
vos femmes mais pour parler de ça
Benjamin Castaldi racontez-nous tout
alors en fait il se trouve que les les
médecins ont accès à un logiciel dans
lequel est prévu un nombre de doses
aujourd'hui il y a 7 doses de prévu
jusqu'à cette dose dans votre passe
sanitaire moi j'ai le mien maintenant il
y a marqué 1 sur 3 ou 3 sur 1 ça veut
dire que c'est j'ai fait le premier
cycle de trois vaccins il y a donc des
équipes il y a donc des sites qui vont
suivre aujourd'hui il est évident qu'on
va aller jusqu'à là il y a cette dose de
prévu une tous les trois mois et ça va
monter jusqu'à 10 tous les trois mois de
7 doses mais tous les trois mois par le
parent donc pas par en gros 4 x 12 vous
allez vous faire vous allez vous faire
piquer quatre fois par an bah non pas 10
non mais les doses une dose une dose
c'est un cycle Cyril donc c'est c'est
compris ce qu'il a dit
vous avez un cycle il vous faut pour
faire un cycle c'est vrai ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'il raconte aujourd'hui il y
a on a on a fait un cycle on a fait oh
mais laissez-moi finir il y a trois
vaccins voilà donc quand vous avez fait
ça voilà merci merci
il y aura jusqu'à 3 cycles par an donc
aujourd'hui parce que ainsi que ces
trois vaccins faites-vous de ma gueule
en fait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les
médecins et ceux qui sont
responsabilités à faire le vaccin ont
déjà 7 doses de prévu je l'ai vu
il y a un logiciel que le professeur va
me confirmer qui s'appelle mais cette 12
ou 7 cycles cette dose
est-ce que c'est vrai deuxième troisième
6e et 7e ça veut pas dire que c'est
grave c'est très simple c'est un
document c'est un site officiel auquel
les médecins et ceux qui sont habilités
à faire le vaccin ça veut dire que
d'ores et déjà on a de prévu 7 doses
c'est incroyable monsieur casino il y a
Myriam Palomba qui voulait te défoncer
tu vas vas-y fais ton plaisir quand j'ai
entendu Benjamin dire ça ce que je me
suis dit soit c'est un gros Ventard qui
veut faire croire qu'il a des infos
avant tout le monde soit c'est un
ignorant et je pense que ça coûte
en fait quand moi je parlais dictature
sanitaire ce genre de choses on le
savait déjà puisque l'Union européenne a
acheté 4,2 milliards de doses l'année
dernière avant même que le Pass
sanitaire soit installé donc on va se
faire piquer neuf fois par an donc c'est
pour 450 millions d'Européens ce qui
correspond à 9 10 doses par habitant
donc quand je parlais de ça oui j'ai la
même info mais surtout je l'avais avant
lui et elle était sortie déjà depuis
hyper longtemps donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on savait déjà depuis le départ que
de toute façon il faudrait se faire
vacciner plusieurs fois pour pour avoir
une immunité enfin façon de parler
puisqu'on sait très bien que ce vaccin
permet de de transmettre et d'être
contaminé et que c'était quelque chose
qui était su donc soit à l'époque moi je
parlais de ça vous me traitiez de
complotistes vous me disiez que j'étais
que je disais des conneries mais
finalement s'avère que tout ce que les
gens disaient comme complotistes s'avère
vrai au fur et à mesure il suffisait
juste de regarder un peu ce qui se
passait à l'échelle européenne et ce qui
se disait notamment au Parlement
européen pour être au courant de ces
choses là visiblement vous ne l'étiez
pas
le logiciel à l'époque excusez-moi
n'affiche une pas assez dose mais trois
doses
une info sans nous dire le nom c'est
quelqu'un voilà qui est médecin qui m'a
dit voilà je viens de recevoir le
nouveau logiciel qui était rectualité 9
fois par heure
[Musique]
puisque c'est tous les trois mois
[Rires]
en juillet c'est important de dire
c'est important c'est qu'on savait déjà
en juillet au moment où on installe le
pas sanitaire les gens savaient déjà ce
qui nous gouvernent à l'échelle
européenne savait déjà que de toute
façon il fallait se faire piquer
plusieurs fois donc
le passage
et protéger les autres mais en fait
c'est une grosse arnaque on savait déjà
depuis le départ que ce vaccin il
fallait le refaire enfin vaccin pseudo
vaccin qu'il fallait le refaire
plusieurs fois pour pour garantir une
immunité oui mais maintenant il y a eu
du temps qui est passé et je pense
qu'ils sont quand même peut-être
j'espère assez intelligent pour se
rendre compte qu'il y a pas tout le
monde qui en a besoin et peut-être que
ça va être pour certains
ils ont acheté 4,2 milliards de doses
donc vous pensez qu'ils vont en faire
quoi ces 4,2 milliards de doses donc
pour l'argent ils vont piquer n'importe
qui ben on va changer aujourd'hui
quand on est face à un irresponsable il
faut le mettre Benjamin Castaldi il faut
le mettre hors d'état de nuire donc moi
je vous le demande solennellement c'est
vous qui décidez de le radier du
vendredi
n'importe quoi sur Secret Story ça passe
mais là et vous allez nous sortir un
document bidon
moi je fais des enquêtes
la rougeole mais pas vous attires
responsable
il est responsable mais ce document il
est bidon est totalement il est en train
ne vous mêlez pas ça si on va régler son
pantalon la défense même si il m'énerve
n'importe quoi
un document sur votre logiciel n'importe
quoi mais quels sont vos sources
Castaldi donne la différence de toi j'ai
fait une enquête j'étais contacté il
aimait tous les mecs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vais attendre je vais attendre que le
professeur dont c'est le métier de te
répondre il n'y a que tu es ce document
il reconnaît très bien la capture
d'écran c'est le logiciel qui est mis à
jour les vaccins et effectivement allô
je te parle
il y a 7 vaccinations prévu donc
tais-toi enregistre et écoute merci
alors tu veux répondre juste de regarder
des documents de la NSM les mêmes la
vaccination pour les les moins de 12 ans
et prévu ils ont même déjà marqué les
protocoles sur le site donc moi je veux
bien que Benjamin disent des conneries
mais il suffit juste de vous renseigner
mais faites pas comme ça vous êtes vous
détenez pas la science infuse pour tout
non plus
Myriam
je suis attaqué
vous avez été vous avez énoncé des
théories farfelues complotisme je vous
ai toujours défendu mais si votre source
votre référence ça devient Castaldi
Benjamin et médecin maintenant c'est
Benjamin je ne suis pas médecin
politique
pas ce que je te dis ce site ce site est
un site officiel
[Rires]
je vous dis que dans le logiciel
pourquoi le covid qui est un
logiciels médecins ont accès mais des
mois parce que vous professeur
je vous dis qu'on va se vacciner tous
les trois mois voilà donc trois fois
tous les trois mois trois fois une dose
tous les trois mois
c'est pas compliqué
merde en tous les cas c'est prévu déjà 7
et c'est vrai jusqu'à 10 tu te fais
piquer donc 9 fois par an voilà
combien de temps pour aller en vacances
du coup pour les profs et en plus et en
plus il va falloir qu'ils les normes qui
soient qui soit établis pour l'ensemble
des pays et tout merci
[Musique]
s
on va se faire piquer 10 fois par an
professeur
après on aura la réponse du professeur
oui on va voir un éthylotest ce qu'on va
voir
en vrai non moi je suis d'accord avec
lui je vois pas pourquoi on est
actionnerait pas 10 fois on a déjà été
vacciné quatre fois et tant que
on est appelé au 4e en tout cas
du gouvernement ne dit pas le covid
c'est fini pour toute la vie je pense
qu'on sera amené à se faire encore
vacciner la deuxième chose qui me gêne
c'est la rétention d'information en fait
on a taxé les antivax de complotisme
mais comment vous voulez ne pas être
complotiste quand en fait on vous cache
la vérité on a la sensation que tout est
décrit à l'avance qui a des gens qui
détiennent certaines informations des
gens haut placé comme disent Benjamin et
qu'on cache la vérité à tout alors les
gens
non mais c'est vrai c'est des infos qui
circulent dans certains milieux Il a 2
ans et peut-être qu'il savait il y a des
mois qu'on allait tous se faire vacciner
10 fois et que nous on le sait pas donc
je comprends qu'on parle
certaines personnes sombres dans le
complotiste mais c'est juste qu'on se
renseigne un petit peu hein
que dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
oui on savait depuis on le savait pas
depuis mais de l'année dernière avant
même que le passage donc faut arrêter de
dire pas du complotiste c'est juste des
gens qui Castaldi a dit vendredi qu'on
aille se faire piquer
il prend sur internet un document mais
non
Kelly ne vous mêlez pas de ça
franchement je te jure que demain tu vas
venir avec moi je te fais bouffer
l'écran
par petit bout ouais je vais te mettre
devant je te fais bouffer l'écran si
j'ai tort je te le fais bouffer par
petites quand on va chez lui pour bosser
le midi il ouvre une bouteille de rose
et picoler complètement bourré
[Applaudissements]
qui va se passer c'est que je pense pas
qu'on va nous administrer toutes ces
doses d'abord Myriam parce que de toute
façon il y a des variants et donc
l'ancien vaccin correspond plus au
nouveau variant donc je pense qu'on va
vacciner les gens les plus fragiles avec
des comorbidités de plus les plus âgés
tous et tout ça mais absolument pas Dido
j'y crois pas du tout et voilà je pense
qu'on aura un rappel par an comme la
grippe en fait moi je croyais pas
sanitaire et pourtant c'est arrivé un
truc je suis curieux moi il était où ils
sont où les variants depuis janvier
janvier février
pourquoi on enlève les masses dans les
transports professeur casanismes
cet après-midi pour m'inviter chez vous
j'ai plutôt confiance en benjamin
excusez-moi
et j'ai quand même vérifié donc je suis
allé regarder bravo je répondrai par
morceau
sur la question de l'ordinateur le
logiciel les logiciels quand on les
développe il faut les développer pour
qu'il dure et on laisse toujours
beaucoup de champs libres un peu comme
un tableau Excel pour tout le monde vous
avez des tonnes de tableaux de colonnes
sur votre droite s'il fallait avoir des
fenêtres en plus et après il faut
s'adapter rapidement et il faut pouvoir
vacciner et pouvoir réagir c'est
impossible ça coûte une fortune il y en
a pas la réactivité donc tous les
logiciels n'importe qui d'un développeur
développe un logiciel laisse toujours la
possibilité d'aller plus loin c'est
normal autrement on achète pas le
logiciel c'est un premier élément
on aurait pu masquer les vaccinations
suivantes je vous rappelle que les
immunodéprimés les personnes âgées ont
pu recevoir plusieurs doses parce que
ils développent pas des anticorps et
pour quelques-uns on a pu faire plus de
doses et patients qui ont un
concertation ou 10 fois par an comme il
a dit il faut alors donc
croyez-moi j'ai potassé je regarde ça on
a regardé des tonnes d'articles et on
échange les articles avec des gens en
France à l'étranger en Amérique latine
aux États-Unis partout en échange donc
c'est pas l'analyse Casalino c'est
vraiment en échange beaucoup de Data
parce que il doit y avoir quelque chose
comme 50000 ou 500 000 articles qui ont
écrit sur qui ont été écrits sur la
covid et sur la vaccination on doit être
pour probablement quelque chose comme
7000 ou 8000 articles multipliés par 25
pages par article vous voyez ce que ça
donne donc il faut être une forme de
frappe il faut être plusieurs il n'y a
pas un article qui aujourd'hui
permettent de dire ça donc ce que dit
Castaldi voilà on va vers une
hypervaccination et il y a plusieurs
vaccination le premier le premier c'est
que nous avons fait trois doses de
vaccin avec trois doses de vaccin nous
avons fait des taux d'anticorps et les
rappels ont été pour faire une immunité
plus solide et durable dans le temps
regardez pour le vaccin contre
l'hépatite B s'il y a quelques-uns parmi
vous qui est vacciné contre l'hépatite
l'hépatite B c'est trois doses il faut
se faire trois doses
et après une fois on fait trois doses et
après on peut avoir des rappels tous les
10 ans en fonction de votre autonome
pour donner un exemple donc
un deuxième élément qui pourrait pousser
à continuer avec ciné c'est que les taux
d'anticorps peuvent diminuer très vite
parce que
particularité du Sark of 2 c'est qu'il a
une incroyable capacité ce [ __ ] à
échapper à notre système immunitaire et
comme il échappe à notre système
immunitaire nous devons en permanence
courir derrière et donc soit on fait
augmenter les taux d'anticorps avec des
vaccins soit on développe des nouveaux
vaccins parce que nous la science évolue
merci merci non parce que si
on développait des nouveaux vaccins des
nouveaux vaccins parce qu'il avait des
nouveaux variants par exemple nos
techniques sont en train de s'améliorer
on travaille sur l'ARN lui-même la RN
messager et d'autres stratégies
vaccinales on travaille sur le lipide
qui accompagne le vaccin pour qu'il soit
mieux cibler dans la cellule et qu'il
induisent une meilleure réponse
immunitaire il y a toute raison de
penser que ces peu crédible et l'autre
argument qui serait les variants vous
l'avez vu Olivier actuellement il y a
des variantes il y a les variantes de
Micron B4 B5 qui sont responsables
d'épidémie actuellement en Afrique du
Sud pour donner un exemple en Australie
il y a eu aussi des repoussés
si c'est nouveau variant
pour lesquels on a démontré que les
schémas actuels protègent encore au
moins des formes graves
si on devait reviner avec des nouveaux
vaccins ces nouveaux vaccins seraient
efficaces et protégeraient des nouveaux
actuellement nous sommes en train de
développer le monde de scientifique
comme je dis nous des nouveaux vaccins
avec peut-être un potentiel de couvrir
tous les variantes voilà tous les
variants multivariants donc
je suis optimiste en même temps Castalie
chez vous une fois la première chose
qu'on a pris de l'épidémie ça va être
humble fermer sa gueule c'est il faut
être prudent
ceux qui paraissait une réalité absolue
en 2020 aujourd'hui c'est la pire des
stupidités donc soyons prudents alors
Myriam miam qu'est-ce-que
aujourd'hui et de protéger les patients
on sait qu'aujourd'hui les ministère
avec ce vaccin ne dure pas qui a 4,2
milliards de doses qui ont été achetés
vous pouvez dire tout ce que vous voulez
venir rassurer les gens etc mais on en
reparle en septembre quand les élections
législatives etc seront passés et je
vous dis vous serez bon pour partir pour
de nouvelles doses
2 milliards de doses qu'on a commandé
donc on va les administrer ah bah on va
vous on va vous demander de faire des
rappels régulièrement dans la mesure qui
ne marchent pas avec ces doses là avec
ces doses là c'est un vaccin qui ne
marche pas et ça de toute façon la
communauté scientifique quand même est
assez unanime pour dire que il ne marche
pas et que même l'immunité naturelle
peut être plus forte que celle-là
moi je suis pas d'accord évidemment
parce que tu veux récupérer le vendredi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non je crois évidemment que le vaccin
marche puisque maintenant il y a plus de
cas graves il y a plus de décès mais si
justement juste petite ce vendredi c'est
moi qui ferai les missions
[Rires]
donc j'espère qu'il y avait pas prévu un
weekend non si non parce que l'oseille
c'est évident que les maintenant les
hôpitaux sont des engorgés qui a plus de
cas avec cetera ça au moins on peut
reconnaître du vaccin en revanche ce que
je sais c'est que par exemple Pfizer qui
font l'ARN messager ils sont en train
d'essayer de développer avec une
nouvelle formulation un vaccin qui
serait un vaccin par an pour le moment
en tout cas et qui prendrait en compte
d'ailleurs tous les variations il y en
aura d'autres on le sait mais bien sûr
qu'il en aura d'autres
Myriam
ça veut dire qu'en fait quand les je
sais pas qui a acheté 4,2 milliards de
doses
je pose juste une question dans ton
esprit ça veut dire que donc ces
personnes qui sont quand même
responsables à quelques un niveau on va
acheter 4,2 milliards de doses sciemment
en disant il y en a beaucoup trop on va
leur fourguer au risque de tuer de
rendre malade des gens c'est ça pour
gagner de l'argent j'essaie de traduire
tu as pensé vous avez regardé les débats
au Parlement européen moi je te regarde
pas j'essaie de traduire tu as pensé pas
sur quelle planète vous vivez votre
question
c'est hallucinant souviens-toi Myriam
quand on avait sur les bras les vaccins
H1 et que au juste
là là on n'arrête pas alors qu'on sait
qu'il y a des effets secondaires donc
juste Benjamin Castaldi parce que c'est
pas par de vous vous avez dit tu as pris
une information que vous avez cette
information c'est juste cette histoire
d'ordinateur ou c'est un vrai médecin on
va être piqué combien de fois là on va
aller jusqu'à 10 doses pas sur un an on
va on va monter jusqu'à 10 donc
effectivement sur le même sur la même
base de vaccin donc dis donc à quel
rythme alors que le professeur Casalino
dit lui
un professeur
de 25 contre la grippe tous les ans
professeur il y a le B il y a deux
variants qui arrivent qui sont en
Afrique du Sud qui vont arriver on le
sait en octobre en septembre en France
et on va nous remettre une dehors c'est
sûr et certain on en remettra une autre
raison bah oui bah évidemment
oui mais ce qui change c'est quand même
le message excusez-moi
si on avait besoin on va se vacciner
pour protéger la population et éviter
les morts les vaccins ont évité des
dizaines de milliers de centaines de
milliers voire des millions de décès
dans le monde
autre chose c'est de dire peu importe
nous sommes gouvernés par des gens qui
sont capables de nous vacciner à mort et
que la communauté médicale
fabriquer en une heure avant
l'ordinateur arrête un peu quoi ridicule
c'est ridicule j'aime bien le côté
anarchiste mais là c'est un peu tout
moche je suis le premier à dire que
comme tout le monde est d'accord je suis
contre je cherche le plan B mais là
c'est imputé une volonté de nuire à la
communauté scientifique imputer une
volonté de nuire à un gouvernement
est-ce que vous êtes dans votre
sa maman quoi parce que la volonté de
nuire et de tuer une acceptable
excusez-moi ou quoi vous êtes en train
de m'accuser de vouloir tuer des gens ou
devenir à des gens vous n'êtes pas en
fait
des choses pareilles
doliprane aux gens des médicaments
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas dire mais
mon étang très gentil que c'est
acceptable
[Musique]
c'est un excellent professeur
non plus parce qu'il y a des millions de
gens qui sont d'accord avec personne
et vouloir les tuer excusez-moi je le
prends en général
pendant la période de la covid c'est que
les gens qui étaient pour les gens qui
étaient contre tout le monde s'est
exprimé merci on va voir ce que pensent
les gens de Benjamin Castaldi c'est
important